hello i'm dr umar malik and welcome to
math simplified
back when i was a medical student we
studied a lot of bacteria
viruses and fungi in great detail
from the structure of these pathogens to
the diseases they cause
the peculiarities they have and the
treatments we use for the disease they
cause
ironically i never thought that a very
short and insignificant paragraph of
four to five sentences in one of my
books
would become the most debated and fear
topic
in the 21st century that topic was
coronavirus
in the past few weeks there has been a
resurgence of new covet 19 cases in few
countries mainly the united kingdom
early in the pandemic few scientists
were worried and expressed their
fears that the coronavirus would mutate
into something more dangerous
unfortunately in november 2020 that fear
was confirmed
when the first variant of the mutant
virus
was discovered the newly discovered
variant was known as the kovite 19b117
and that was associated with a huge
spike in cases in south east england and
london
so in this video we'll be talking about
covet mutations and what it means for us
so let's begin by taking a brief look at
mutations and how they happen
in biology a mutation is anything that
leads to a change in the genetic
material
the same genetic material which is
responsible for each and every aspect of
a cell's existence
genetic material controls how a cell
grows works
acts reacts and eventually dies these
mutations can happen for several reasons
it can happen because of errors damage
by radiation
or by chemicals in fact mutations even
occur randomly
so mutations may be bad for the organism
may be neutral
or maybe even beneficial for the
organism
so you may be wondering how mutation
affects covid19
well kobit 19 uses a special protein to
attach to our body cells
these proteins are known as spike
proteins which help the covet virus to
latch onto our cells and initiate the
infection
mutations in these proteins are helping
the virus to bind more tightly to our
cells
making it more infectious also mutations
in this region allows the virus to evade
our body's own immune system effectively
growing unrestricted
this mutation that is keeping scientists
awake at night has been termed
e-484-k on 1st december 2021
uk reported a total of 14 000 cases a
day with a declining trend
and after this train on 5th january 2021
uk was reporting a record high of 60 000
cases per day
with an increasing trend the new strain
has been found to be more contagious
than the previous ones
even the cdc said that multiple lines of
evidence indicate that b117 is more
efficiently transmitted than
the other sars cover 2 variants
researchers from uk biobank found
that most people infected with covad19
keep the antibodies for three
to six months however if you come in
contact with another strain of the virus
such as the highly contagious variant
from the uk
your antibodies may not be able to
protect you and the doctors believe your
rate of reinfection could
be high this is worrisome as this can
increase the reinfection rates of
coronavirus especially in critically
and chronically ill patients what does
this mean for us
in the present for the time being things
are looking up
the world seems to have understood the
importance of tackling swift and
decisive action
as soon as a news of new strain broke
countries closed foreign travel
especially from the united kingdom
as far as the people who had already
returned they and their respective
contacts were traced
placed into quarantine and promptly
tested even countries like india where
over 10 million people have been
affected by kovid already have
successfully controlled the spread of
this foreign strain
well here things are a bit fishy to find
the effectiveness of the existing
vaccine
options against a new strain studies
were carried out in new york
texas and cambridge they tested the
antibodies
of newly vaccinated citizens against the
new covid19 strain
their results showed that while the
effectiveness of the vaccine to prevent
against the variants carrying the e484k
mutation was slightly reduced for some
people
it was still within an acceptable level
it is worth bearing in mind however that
the above studies are based on a very
small sample of numbers and any
conclusions
are not definitive this mutation is a
peak into the possible future
a future where covet brings out newer
surprises
and uncertainties we are yet to
understand the long-term consequence of
this pandemic
another mutated strain may not be far
away but on the positive note all hope
is not lost
we have new knowledge and previous
experience to prepare ourselves
we have a worldwide mass vaccination
program coordinated by companies all
over the globe
and supported by governments that can
potentially solve this problem for good
we are researching drugs newer therapies
and
alternative medicine to decrease the
burden governments are actively taking
steps
such as mass media campaigns social
awareness increasing health expenditure
and coordinating with scientific experts
to eliminate this disease so friends i
hope you found this video helpful
if you did make sure to hit the like
button below to support us you can also
support my simplified by clicking the
join button below or by joining our page
at patreon.com
thank you so much for watching see you
in the next video